il ya un an aujourd'hui un tireur fou
faisait irruption dans une école
primaire de nhu thành au connecticut et
faisait 26 victimes dont 20 enfants
alors que la tragédie et son souvenir
relance le débat sur le contrôle des
armes à feu aux états unis une autre
fusillade a éclaté hier dans une école
secondaire du colorado faisant un blessé
un mort le tireur qui avait 18 ans l'un
de nos lèvres
plus de 2000 élèves fréquentent l'école
secondaire d'art à parrot à sentenial en
banlieue de denver
on est à peine à 20km de columbine et
d'aurora la scène est beaucoup trop
familière armé d'un fusil de chasse car
personne 18 ans aurait visé un
enseignant les policiers croient qu'il
voulait se venger mais de quoi ses
confrères et consoeurs de classe se
rappelle de lui comme d'un étudiant
agréable intelligent incapable d'une
telle violence unique bémol il aurait
récemment eu un désaccord avec
l'enseignant responsable de l'équipe de
débats oratoires
selon ce que raconte certains élèves
l'enseignant prévenu quitte rapidement
les lieux
le corps de pierre je me retrouvais dans
une salle de classe
si les enquêteurs ne font pas de lien
mais l'incident coïncide avec le premier
anniversaire de la tuerie de new town au
connecticut ou 20 enfants et six adultes
ont péri aujourd'hui plusieurs villes se
montre solidaire à leur façon mais la
communauté demandent à vivre cet
anniversaire loin des objectifs des
caméras
la commémoration officielle a eu lieu à
washington jeudi
car dans son discours hebdomadaire
barack obama souligner le triste
anniversaire et réitère son plaidoyer
pour un meilleur contrôle des armes à
feu et des soins a crû en santé mentale
si certains états comme le connecticut
ont adopté des lois plus contraignante
le sénat a rejeté cette année un projet
qui aurait prévu des vérifications plus
exhaustive des antécédents et ce à
l'échelle nationale
le problème actuellement aux etats unis
c'est que si vous achetez une arme dans
un magasin spécialisé oui on vérifie
mais si vous achetez une arme
admettons souvent une arme personnes
vérifient si vous allez à une foire
d'armes à feu le bf damas personnes
vérifient des groupes de militants
rapporte 28 fusillade dans des écoles
depuis new town au cours de la dernière
année plus de trente mille personnes
sont mortes par balles aux états unis
deux cents d'entre elles des enfants nés
un lièvre radio canada montréal